how do you top something as big as Mary
Poppins well getting almost the exact
same group together helps yeah the same
director the same song teen some of the
same actors let's work in a story that's
very similar maybe not a magic nanny but
a witch and maybe not Julie Andrews but
Angela Lansbury and maybe not Britain
but yeah okay still Britain but
completely different kids this resulted
in Bedknobs and Broomsticks what in many
respects should have been just sort of
the lame knockoff trying to recapture
the Mary Poppins feeling actually does
become its own unique thing and it's fun
and imaginative and catchy and funny and
has Nazis in it yeah we'll get to that
but let's start from the beginning its
World War two and a lot of our men are
sent to war which means that a lot of
kids have to live in foster homes so
three of them are sent to live with mrs.
price who is not on board with the idea
but the government says that she has no
choice so she takes them in and
eventually they find out her secret that
she is in fact a witch originally the
kids tried to blackmail her with it but
then they remember oh yeah she's a witch
and they decide to play nice but trouble
comes in brewing when she realizes that
the program that she was getting all her
spells from is closing down and just
before the most important spell was
going to be sent you see she was hoping
to use this Bell to end the war but
without it she can't do a thing so they
use her magic to travel on a bed to the
guy who created the program professor
Brown who we find out is actually
nothing more than a con artists magician
you see he never actually believed in
the magic he was viewing out he was just
doing it to make a quick buck but when
he finds it works for mrs. price money
signs appear in his eyes and he decides
to take advantage of it
at least tries to she keeps trying to
get the final piece of the spell to win
the war and he just wants to utilize her
to get some money so through a ton of
traveling in various locations and a
bunch of different spells they go from
one magic situation to another magic
situation including bringing objects to
life traveling to an island where the
animals rule and even getting a chance
to take down the Nazi army with their
final spell so yeah let's talk about
that elephant in the room first the
climax of this movie is actually
fighting off Nazis then it's done in a
comedic fun over-the-top way you
you could make the argument that this is
really bad taste in the same way that
maybe Hogan's Heroes is kind of bad
taste but even though it's clear they're
bad guys you never really see them do
anything that horrible even the mission
they're on is more of a training
exercise than it is actual killing
people they're not made to look super
horrible there's definitely some comedic
moments with them but yeah you could
argue that makes it even kind of worse
what we're supposed to kind of be
laughing with Nazis and showing our kids
this some sensitivities are definitely
gonna be jeopardized here so just know
this is the climax of the movie and it
never gets bloody or gritty but like I
said some people might take that the
wrong way too with that said the movie
is really charming and really
entertaining how we said this is sort of
what the Harry Potter movies could have
been if they wanted to have a little bit
more fun with their idea and not take it
so damn seriously and that's what this
movie does it has fun it goes from fun
location to fun location introduces
great song after great song great dance
number after great dance number some
great effects and at the center of it is
Angela Lansbury and David Tomlinson who
are both fantastic they take these roles
so seriously but not to a point where
it's distracting it's to a point where
they totally suck you in
even in scenes where they're talking
with anime characters it never looks
like they're turning to the camera and
winking like yeah we know this is kind
of stupid you just totally believe
they're really there because it seems
like they really believe they're really
there I also love how David Tomlinson is
sort of this likable scoundrel he is a
con artist but at the same time he's not
a bad guy and yeah we do have to go
through that scene where he tries to go
away thinking that the family didn't get
to him and that he doesn't care even
though you know he's gonna go back and
yeah it's stupid but you put up with it
to get to the fun climax the songs
fantastic again it's the Sherman
Brothers some of the best song writers
of all time and these are some of their
best songs
mother wishes away is the Spode the
slapstick when they traveled to the
island fill with animals is a little
long but I don't mind because I love
slapstick and this is some good stuff
the timing the sound effects it's all
perfect the climax again depending on
your sensitivity to the whole Nazi thing
it's still friggin awesome it's so cool
how they can build up this great comedy
but also this great epic size to it I
mean just look how cool this is seeing
all this armor come to life and listen
to that kick-ass chant that the God
like I said it's mostly played for
laughs but it's pretty cool too if I did
have a problem with the movie I would
say that the child actors aren't that
great I mean the girl does okay but the
two boys are nothing that great
Charlie's delivery is a little too
deadpan and Paul oh man I mean think
he's trying but in there kids and
they're not really the focus the focus
is on our two main characters as where
it should be now there is one thing
that's really important to note about
this movie if you do see it make sure
you see the original cut if you get it
on DVD they usually give you the
extended and that's not the one you want
to see I know a lot of times I always
say oh they left stuff out and they
should put it back in but when they put
it back in in this version it goes on
forever and this movie is already pretty
long I mean some parts are okay like
David Tomlinson has a song sequence I
was cut out that's actually kind of fun
there's one or two moments are kind of
neat to see but for example the
Portobello Road sequence in the original
it's really great it's this long kind of
party going on with all these different
ethnicities and cultures coming together
and having a great time and when it's
done you really sad that it's done and
there's sort of this emptiness like the
party is over and oh you just want to go
on forever well the other cut it does go
on forever and ever and ever and ever
and oh my god it'll just never end it
was a song sequence with mrs. price
after professor Brown leaves where she
sings about how much she misses him and
it's nice I guess
but is it really needed doesn't it kind
of go without saying that she really
misses him little additions like that
can really make it drag on so I would
strongly advise if you are gonna see
this film try to see the original and
not the extended cut only check that out
if you're curious to see some of the
missing scenes which are neat but way
too long but with that said I say this
is kind of similar to Mary Poppins even
if it does take sort of a different
direction that's more of
action-adventure that is a charming
little kids story hell you could argue
it's like Mary Poppins with swords what
the hell's wrong with that I absolutely
love it I love the story I love the
characters I love the performances I
love the songs I love
it's an awesome adventure that's
definitely worth checking out
you